this season of sex ed is brought to you
by Lilo stick around until after the
episode to learn a little bit more I
still thought maybe I was bi so I was
like maybe this will be like my grand
reveal if I can have sex with a man and
a woman at the same time but really I
was just so gay that I was willing to
have sex with a man in order to have sex
with this girl
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
real you know I've never done it I don't
think scissoring is actually a thing
honestly in my experience I could be
wrong the one time I tried it it really
didn't feel like anything and we stopped
after about 30 seconds and moved on to
better things it's completely dependent
on the person you're with I would say
it's mostly not real it can be fun but
it's like a lot of work and very tiring
and why do you want to have an ab
workout when you're trying to have sex
have you ever had sex with a man yes I
have after going through like Christian
therapy and stuff I was like okay I can
convince myself that I'm straight so I
just need to be with guys there was
never that spark there was never that
connection I was really into this girl
at a Halloween party we were like
kissing on the balcony and she was like
let's bring Tony in and I was like okay
cool who's Tony she's like oh it's my
boyfriend and I'm like
and I still thought maybe I was bi so I
was like maybe this will be like my
grand reveal if I can have sex with a
man and a woman at the same time but
really I was just so gay that I was
willing to have sex with a man in order
to have sex with this girl I haven't had
full-on sex with a man but I have hooked
up with one we got to the more intimate
parts and it was more of just oh okay
this is kind of happening my girl here
is it hard when starting out to date
women
yeah so I can I could definitely relate
I was really scared when I started to
date women you just have to like get
yourself out there and if that's what
you want then like it's definitely worth
it I've seen questions like this a lot
especially from bisexual women because
they're really scared to start dating
women and it can be kind of intimidating
women are so open and like communicative
I don't expect you to like know
everything like I don't know everything
myself so you have nothing to be scared
about if you're like bi and we're fem
presenting then like dating women is
probably a little bit more difficult but
if you kind of look like I do then like
you'll get like a DM here or there I
mean it's just as hard as dating a guy
like you know if you know how to talk
and flirt and make jokes like it'll be
fine I don't know how to be any
different I almost think it's easier to
date women all the men that I ever liked
or had any kind of relationship with I
always felt like I was trying so hard I
don't feel that pressure
when I'm with a girl if you haven't
dated a girl before I honestly think
it's going to be a lot easier than you
might be expecting it to be do you
always finish
yes I think that's definitely something
with lesbian relationships at least from
what I've heard from friends it's like
such a big emphasis is on making sure
that everyone's taken care of I'm a
switch but I'm more top so if for me
like the focus is if the like the girl
that I'm having sex with if she finishes
or not I take on a more dominant role in
bed
um so typically I'm not the one that's
like receiving the pleasure so finish
physically no finish mentally every time
I always say women knows a woman's body
so I know I can please a woman and I
know that she can please me so yes we
always both end up finishing because
it's like we know what to do because I
do it to myself so I can do it to you
how was your first time it was really
nice actually it was with this person
that I met on Tinder we went on a few
dates and then we came back to my house
I wasn't really expecting
um to have sex that day but we watched a
movie and it led to it my first time was
with a guy
and it was really awkward because I
didn't tell him that I was a virgin so
we just was like boom in it and I was
like just taking it and then like once
you know whatever happened and saw the
blood he was like why you didn't tell me
I'm so sorry and then after that I was
like yeah this is really not for me we
literally did it for like 12 hours like
I remember the sun coming up that was
like my first like real kiss my first
real everything all in one amazing like
Saturday night I like just could feel
something was gonna happen I was like
it's gonna be a spicy night so I like
went on PornHub and I just typed in like
how to have lesbian sex and I like
watched like two videos they weren't
very helpful and then it was fine it was
very like we were laughing a lot and it
was like it was a good time I feel like
both of us kind of had no idea what we
were doing and then after that it only
kind of went uphill
um is penetration important for you
during sex usually there is penetration
but it's definitely not like necessary
to have sex like there's other things
you can do without penetration it really
just depends on what the other girl
wants for me I guess it's always been
the part of it that I look forward to
the most so in that regard I would say
yes it's important to me but I don't
think it's something that you have to
have however you have to do and in a lot
of in a lot of instances it's a little
underwhelming I feel like that's like
the joy of like being a lesbian it's
like there's so many different things
that you can do it's it's literally just
like picking like okay like what do I
want today here's like this basket or
like going to the grocery store there's
all these things on the shelf and like
you can just like put into your basket
whatever you want that day and like
penetration does not have to be on the
Shelf what kind of porn do you watch
watch porn anymore to be honest I
haven't watched porn in so long just
because it's so fake like it like does
not turn me on anymore like the lesbian
Dynamic of porn is so unique because you
know you can watch it and like even
though there are two women having sex
you can tell they don't really like it
and then obviously that's a turn off
because you're like this is
uncomfortable this is awkward she's not
actually having pleasure she's like
screaming for The Vibes I actually know
a lot of lesbians who watch like gay
male porn surprisingly like half of my
friends say that that's what they watch
because it is like a real connection do
people fetishize you often when I was in
like San Francisco and I'd be on the
train taking the muni um every once in a
while there would be like some Bros in
the back with if me and my partner were
like sitting together they'd be like
Kiss Kiss just for us come on babes like
ew like definitely Femme lesbians tend
to get fetishized more just they try to
like throw them into threesomes a lot of
time times people have said like you
don't look like a lesbian what does a
lesbian look like people be like can you
show me can you like prove it to me can
you like kiss a girl for me no there are
so many people who seem to think that
lesbians only exist for their enjoyment
I always get lots of messages from guys
saying that they can turn me it's like a
challenge there's not a lot of respect
there for sure I feel like I come off
pretty masculine but like feminine girls
also like they can't fetishize so much
and like when I'm with them too it's
like it's crazy it's like it's really
gross
um what's the biggest misconception
about lesbian sex or sexuality yeah some
people think it's just a phase and that
you'll ultimately like men or that
you'll be down for a threesome or
something it's really not the case
sounds like my worst nightmare honestly
I feel like people assume that all
lesbians are the like very mask
presenting dominating one and then the
like super submissive of girly one which
is just not true it's kind of true in
some relationships I hear a lot like
have you ever had real sex like have you
not just like met the right man you just
kind of have this feeling you like meet
a person you get this Vibe and you like
want to have sex with them or you don't
and there's nothing wrong with that but
it has nothing to do with like have you
met the right dick like you know I feel
like it's the thing of not using
protection because now that you're
dating a woman like I can't get pregnant
STDs basically don't bother me which is
not true you know you still need to get
tested and use protection sex is really
important to talk about so you can know
how to handle it and if it is for you
how you know how does it fit in your
life and all that stuff so yeah
I feel like I'm looking at this wrong oh
it turns on
coin you could just like stick in your
pocket okay let's go
whoa
oh oh
hey hey I mean it's good to keep
educating yourself son what's out there
the advancements being made like this is
pretty Sleek stuff going on how far does
it go 12 meters 12 meters I don't know
what that is I only know feet
I'm just going to hold this up and
you'll just read it straight off with a
cute card Tiani 3 is specifically
designed to be worn by women the
powerful vibrations provide targeted
Sensations while the smooth silicone
design gives the ultimate pleasure and
comfort delivering satisfying vibrations
to both Partners at once oh to both
that's interesting maybe we're taught
that toys are such a self-pleasuring
thing and it doesn't have to be because
I think that Fosters more communication
with your partner when it comes to like
pleasuring each other and I think this
is like a great conversation starter
your pleasure is your own and Lilo knows
it educate yourself about your own body
and your own pleasure first in order to
enjoy sharing it with a partner go to
lilo.com to learn more
foreign
[Music]